hi there today we'll look at how to
represent
part hole hierarchies in a neural
network by the legend himself
jeffrey hinton he describes a system
also known as
glom that is a new approach
to processing visual information using
neural networks and interestingly
the paper starts off by saying this
paper
does not describe a working system
so this is an idea paper jeffrey
hinton's
suggestion of how we should go about
solving vision
or furthering vision in the ai
community he says openly these are just
ideas
please prove me right prove me wrong try
them out
and so on and i absolutely welcome this
idea papers is a thing that i think we
have lost as a community because
everything needs to be state of the art
and so on
uh this is super cool and i encourage
more people to do it
i'm not saying you're gonna have the
same kind of success with an idea paper
as jeff hinton
he is banking on his name in large part
with this but nevertheless uh it's just
an archive paper like i see people
complaining
this would never be possible if it
wasn't yeah it wouldn't
like people wouldn't pay attention but
you're welcome to write your ideas
and post them on archive like
or write a blog post make a youtube
video uh anyone has opinions
so you know go ahead um yeah
so to the paper itself glom column as
you can see here
column comes from the is stems from
agglomeration
is a system that
instead it presents a single idea about
representation which allows advances
made by several different groups to be
combined into a an imaginary system
called glom
the advances include transformers neural
fields contrastive
representation learning distillation and
capsules
glom answers the question how can a
neural network with
fixed architecture parse an image into a
part
whole hierarchy which has different
structure for each
image the idea is simply to use
islands of identical vectors to
represent the nodes in the parse
tree if glom can be made to work it
should significantly improve the
interpretability
of the representations produced by
transformer like systems when applied to
vision or
language that's the abstract we'll dive
into the system
we'll see what it's about i think i can
actually make
a suggestion to improve it uh but
maybe i'm way behind other folks so
what is the glom system and what are
these parse tree about and why does it
combine all of these things and for that
we look at so hinton has two
core diagrams here this is the first
diagram
this is the second diagram and at first
sight they have little to do with each
other
so let me try to go about it like this
if
you have an image and hinton looks at
vision very much in terms of you have an
image
or a video and you want to
parse the image into kind of a tree
and the tree should be sort of like
a tree of objects and their parts
so let's say it's an image of a car so
the whole notion is very very
object centric so this is like my best
attempt
at a car and
a parse tree for this image would look
something like this alright
so this whole thing here is a car so
that's going to be your top node
in the parse tree the car has different
parts
namely it has this
cabin it has a motor and it has wheels
so that is going to be those are going
to be kind of
downstream of that parse tree then
the cabin itself is going to have two
segments here windows and maybe here is
the door area
so that is going to be window window
door
and so on so you get that we what we
want to do is we want to look at an
image
sort of create this parse tree over here
this is very much into the
into the area of go phi good
old-fashioned ai
people that want to understand
the world in terms of their symbolic
representations and
relation of these symbols to each other
however
what hinton is saying is that if you
simply do this
it's it's you know you can't really do
this with neural networks neural
networks are continuous and so on
so what would you have to do in in
addition we know
that the brain doesn't reconfigure
itself
every single time you get a new input
so the brain even though it has some
neural plasticity
while you look at the world and do
inference in the world
the connections stay the same so what we
need to do is we need to come up
with a system that when we input one
image it can give us
one parse tree but when we input another
image
it can give us some kind of other parse
tree maybe now there are two
objects in the image and this one
has one descendant only which in turn
has two descendants
and so on you see the point the tree
structure needs to be different
each time this in part was addressed by
hinton's capsule networks so in the
capsule networks hinton's idea
was sort of okay i'm going to have these
capsules here in different layers
and i'm going to have kind of lots of
capsules and
these layers lots of capsules in these
layers and
i'm going over capsules because it's
kind of important
here so hinton's idea with
capsules was that the first layer of
capsules would sort of
recognize the the smallest parts so this
would be kind of the wheel capsule
and this would be sort of the window
capsule
and so on so there would be a single
capsule for every part that could
possibly be in an image right you
already see the limitations
because if you want to recognize the
whole world
you need many capsules but nevertheless
this was the idea so a capsule would be
active
if there was the given object
in the image and then the next thing
here this would be kind of the
the motor capsule so the motor
motor capsule and this would be the
cabin capsule and so on so the
window would activate the cabin capsule
but the door capsule would also activate
the cabin
capsule and so on and the wheel would
maybe activate
it would maybe activate i don't know the
wheel should probably be
here as well wheel at this level would
activate that and then all of these
things here would activate the car
capsule sorry
so you can see that
this parse tree here is generated
dynamically right these connections this
routing in capsules
is generated every time different so in
the next image there could be a
different object different capsules are
activated different things are routed
together
the parser is different however you need
these many many
capsules for that every one capsule per
possible part in the image and
that was just infeasible and also the
routing
was very cumbersome in these capsules
so here we go with a new approach and
this new approach
is what
hinton describes as the glom
architecture is composed of a
large number of columns which all
use exactly the same weight each column
is a stack of
spatially local auto encoders that learn
multiple levels of representation for
what is happening
in a small image patch okay so
we're going to build up some kind of
imagination here at the
at the bottom level we have our image so
our image is going to be
lying flat on the ground maybe you can
see it like this
and it is going to be divided into
pixels or small patches whatever you
want but these are
would be called locations so it would be
divided
like this into different locations
i am not good at perspective drawing in
any case
above each location there would be one
of these columns
and these columns i can draw one here
these columns would sort of stack up
like this
and these columns would be divided into
multiple levels so there would be a
bottom level which would be this there
would be
a middle level higher level and so on
hinton suggests about five levels should
probably do
and every single level of this column
tries to represent the location at the
image
right this location down here in
a different resolution so the very
bottom
level might be aware that there is a
part of a wheel like let's say this is
actually let's say this is a cat i
so here there's
probably yup yep
okay so you can see there is
there is a an ear or a part of an ear
let's say there's a part of an ear in
this
location so the very bottom thing would
probably represent
something like the very structure of the
fur
so the bottom thing would represent
what's going on at you know the micro
level really the
location level the next layer would
represent
what's going on at this location in a
kind of a broader sense so that might
recognize that that that's an e
that's actually part of an ear right so
it goes beyond the location if you think
convolutional neural networks you're in
the right ballpark
but we're going to implement this
differently the next
layer will recognize well this location
is part
of a of a cat
of a cat's head
and then the next location will
recognize well this thing is part of a
cat so at this location there's a cat
now there there is a cat at other places
but at this location there is a cat and
so on
so maybe we don't have more and
dislocate at this particular image
but if you consider a different column
like
this this column right here
and you look at what's going on in that
column you'll see
similar so in the top layer let's just
consider the
cat the top layer in the top layer it
might say
well there's a cat too but it there it's
also part
of it's part of a cat's neck
neck and then here it's
maybe there's a bunch of uh well
i don't know a chin and
there is also a fine first structure of
the chin
so you get the idea every column will
build up
these rep these representations and
these are vectors
so these are embedding vectors so at the
bottom location you'd have
the fur vector and then this vector is
the ear
whereas here over here the chin would be
very different
it would be a different vector at the
same layer so
the only thing that agrees here is the
cat vector the cat vector
in this top layer would agree between
both of these columns i hope you get the
idea
you have a column above each of the
locations
every single layer in the column
represents that particular location
but at a different abs level of
abstraction and a different level of i
don't want to say resolution but it
it would consider more and more of its
neighbors
the question is how does it consider its
and how do you learn these things right
so how do you learn these different
abstractions
and that's where these columns they
communicate with each other
so hinton imagines that this is a
process
over time where the columns
iteratively communicate to each other
and within the column the layers
communicate to each other
and this is one of these first diagrams
right here
so this is one single column over time
okay this is this would be the this
would be the fur
at the ear this would be the cat's ear
and this would be cat okay
so
the information that so the embeddings
are updated
by sending information around every
single embedding which means that every
single vector at every single layer of
every single column
is updated by simply averaging
four things so we have the embedding
at layer l at time step t
plus one is going to be sorry at
layer l location x is going to be
a sum between the four parts the four
following parts it's going to be
the embedding at the last time step
right so this is
sort of a recurrent neural network
we the new embedding is the old
embedding
plus it's going to be a function
at a top down that's what a hinton calls
top down function of the embedding
at the same location in the previous
time step
at one layer above so l plus one
it is also going to be receiving
information
from the upwards i think bottom up
because the bottom up embedding of layer
l minus one
at the same location at time step t
all right so this would that's what you
can see right here
the green arrows are
each level each layer simply passes
information to the next time step this
is
if any if nothing else happens you just
keep
your embedding then each embedding
also sends itself through a neural
network
one layer above itself
that's the blue arrows so the blue
arrows here
are these and you every everything
is a neural network here every arrow
except the green ones but the green ones
could be two
so every arrow is a neural network so
this is a neural network
sending information above and this is
intuitive right so the ear
embedding would sort of send information
about itself like saying like hey i'm a
cat ear
sends it above and it goes through a
neural network because it needs to be
transformed
the neural network has to learn well if
it's a cat ear
at that level it might be a cat
at the top level and
lastly every single layer sends
information down and that is the
red arrows right here they're also
neural networks
so the cat ear says well i'm a cat ear
so downstream of myself there might be
you know
some first structure right so all of
these embeddings they try to predict
each other they try to predict
the neighbors of themselves and hinton's
idea is
that by aggregating over time
they will sort of reach a consensus of
what
is in these columns okay there are a few
things missing right here
the one thing that's missing and hinton
pointed this out
that all of these different columns that
we've drawn
they use the same weights okay so
and he discusses this at the end of a
paper it's not really biologically
plausible
but there's an ensemble effect we won't
go into that
but all these these so the blue arrows
are always the same for each time step
uh but not necessarily the same between
different layers
so that might be this f might be
different from this
f down here however the function
passing information from from layer l to
layer l plus one
is the same in every single column
across the image it's a bit like a
convolutional network in terms of
weight sharing so you can imagine it as
one by one convolutional
network in that sense but except the
information does not only go
up the layers it also goes down the
layers
over time so as i said this is an
iterative
procedure it goes up down and laterally
the second thing is now that you ask oh
well if
every single column has the same weights
wouldn't that simply sort of
how how can you localize any information
and the answer is
that you have a side input like in a
neural field
you have a side input annotating each
location basically a positional encoding
honestly so in in addition
to what the image patch looks like you
also get
your kind of either your x y coordinates
or you could also get your relative
coordinates
to some other coordinate frame in there
and so the network knows where it is
and that's going to be important because
what hinton wants to build
are these islands so the imagination of
hinton is that this is going to be
somewhere
in between like after time step 10
and you want to run it for a hundred and
he imagines
that there will what will emerge are
these
sort of islands so imagine the image is
now
a 1d vector down here or you can imagine
these columns in 2d
whatever fits you know whatever fits
your brain better
but imagine the images the image
is simply a 1d line right here
he imagines that the bottom vectors they
will just you know happily
kind of be describing whatever that is
at the very bottom level
but then at the next level once it goes
to sort of higher res or lower
resolution
higher abstraction there
will be there must necessarily be
vectors
that are the same if the system works
and look at these two vectors
and look at these two vectors they are
the same because
they now describe objects that are
larger than one location
right the cat's head is larger than
simply one location
therefore at the layer that represents
the cat's head
you expect because these are all all
neural
all the up and down functions in the
same layer have the same weight
you expect that the embedding of
a cat's head is the same in
in the different columns right that this
is
if the system works this must be the
case and then as you go up you expect
more and more
of these what hinton calls islands to
emerge
right so they they agree and the idea
um the idea between all of this message
passing is that over time all of these
things
kind of reinforce each other so we
looked at a column
before and we maybe said okay
so this vector down here it gets
information from the top
uh saying hey uh you know there's a cat
here so you might be like a cat ear
or a cat eye or something like this and
then he gets information from the bottom
saying well there's a bit of
there's you know fur here and there's
some cartilage showing and so on
and it has already sort of figured out
that it might be an
ear and these informations they own they
reinforce itself now like they'd be like
okay
you know you're saying i'm part of a
head and you're saying there's a bit of
fur and cartilage
and i already kind of noticed that i'm a
bit like an ear
so i'm probably more an ear so the idea
is that over time you have this
consensus algorithm
there's one thing missing and that is
how do the different columns communicate
with each other
so i said there are different parts
there is one missing
and that one missing is
going to be i'm just going to call it
whatever
a and a is going to be
an attention mechanism across
all the other columns at the same layer
so if we look here
this cell receives information from
above from below
from itself and also in an attention
mechanism way it's going to receive
information
from all of the different
all of the different embeddings at the
same layer
you can see um
that you know hidden puts in everything
we got in here
now the attention he says is easier
and so these are the four parts right
here
uh at each discrete time and in each
column separately
the embedding at a level is updated to
be the weighted average of four
contributions
the prediction produced by the bottom-up
neural net acting on the embedding
at the level below at the previous time
the prediction produced by the top-down
neural net
acting on the embedding at the level
above at the previous time
the embedding vector at the previous
time step these three
we got and then the attention weighted
average of the embeddings at the same
level right at the same level
in nearby columns at the previous time
so nearby he oh sorry he later
backpedals a bit i think on nearby and
what nearby
exactly means and he at some parts
so this this is idea i think this is
still up for debate
and this is i think where i can help um
but what he wants to do is he wants to
aggregate
he wants to attention aggregate and he
wants to simplify
attention so instead what we usually
have
is we're going to produce queries
and keys and values queries
keys and values and they're all going to
be different functions
of our input and then
we're going to do query times key
transposed
softmax of that times value and that is
going to be
our tension mechanism that allows you
know arbitrary information to be routed
around and so on
hinton says nope what i want
is simply that all the queries the keys
and the values they're all just
equal to the embeddings themselves
so the
attention mechanism would work out to be
the soft max
of x times x transposed times
x and what that does is
if you yourself are the query and every
vector
also itself is the key what do you
attend to
you attend two vectors that are very
similar to yourself
and you can see that in hinton's diagram
the one we circled dark blue what would
it attend
to well it would probably attend to its
left-hand neighbor
the one you can see circled i'm gonna
circle it
this one it will probably attend a lot
too this one it might not attend so much
and the ones over here it might not
attend at
all what does this give us especially
since the values are
also these vectors this is a consensus
algorithm
it is not meant as a way to pass
information around it is not meant like
in a transformer as a way to do
computation because we have no
trainable weights in this process it is
simply meant
as a consensus algorithm so it imagines
that
by doing this by sort of attending
to things that are similar to you and
then integrating their values
there will be these islands forming and
that's what you see
right here you can imagine if two
vectors are already close
at the same layer this mechanism will
make them even
closer so this is a sort of a clustering
algorithm and so the
my question is that these drawings
you look at them they are very
specifically constructed
they are constructed such that a parse
tree is
emerging so when you
look at this you have a clear sense i
can probably
i can probably move all of that crap
out of the way you can see the parse
tree
right because the black thing
is going to be the top node right here
let's leave away the scene level
embedding for now
the black thing is going to be the top
note
and then it has two child notes this one
and this one and then it has four
every one of those has two child notes
but it's not it doesn't have to be
in this case so this dynamically and
every one of them
you know the black ones are individual
this is dynamically constructing a parse
tree right the parse tree here is
something like this and then
[Music]
so this is pretty cool but it is also
drawn deliberately
such that a core problem does not arise
and the core problem
would be something like well um
what if this vector here was actually
also pointing like this
okay so it is not in it is not in the
same
it is not in the same area of the parse
tree right if you go down
the parse tree it is actually here
now if we do what hinton says and
if for this vector here
we do this aggregation via attention on
the same
layer what we will attend to is this
vector
over here now this is probably not meant
to be
because this vector over here it can
represent the same thing but
you can see it's not in the in the same
path of the
parse tree and he mentions this
a little bit throughout but not
necessarily
clear um and the drawing
makes it seem like there is no problem
but i hope you can see
how this is a problem the attention
would pull in information from over here
however the whole parse tree here and
the island on the top layer
suggests that these two things should be
parsed independently from each other and
therefore
also processed independently from each
other so here
is my suggestion to uh
to extend this and maybe hinton's
already thought of this
but i would suggest that this attention
mechanism
here is modulated
by how close two things are
in the parse tree okay so
what would that be so for a a given
vector
it would be how much do you attend to
this vector right here
well a lot because it agrees with you
right it
you know this the soft max of the inner
product would be
high it agrees with you and also it is
in the same
in the same branch of the parse tree so
that's
perfect right this one right here
doesn't agree with you but is in the
same branch so it could potentially
later
agree with you through a consensus
algorithm however this one over here
i you probably shouldn't attend to that
too much even though
it points in the same direction because
it's in a different branch of the parse
tree you shouldn't attend zero to it
like because
these branches on top they could change
and you know by
you sending information there this one
could change
the the top structure here that could
agree more
with your branch of the parse tree and
so on so my suggestion
would be that let's not only
get the soft max of the um
let's not only get the soft max of the
current layer
things but let's do x times and here
we're going to have a sum
so this is going to be k and let's say
we're at
we're at layer l and this is
layer one this is layer two this is
layer three
i'm gonna number them from the top
actually from the bottom
ah layer m layer m minus one and this is
layer
l i'm i suck at this so from the current
layer i wanna go
up the hierarchy until layer one
and i'm going to take this soft max of
the representation
at layer l at layer k
where i'm at x k transposed
like this what we aggregate
is still the um the values on the
current
layer but how much we should attend to
that should be dependent on the parse
tree
and we do that like this and maybe we
have like a kind of a lambda
k l minus k
l minus k i hope you get what i mean
so how much how much you aggregate this
sum here this sum here is weird
um this should go probably
ah hi it's future yannick and i just
wanted to write that down
again so because i've made some mistakes
uh obviously the sum here
should be within the softmax because you
want to kind of aggregate the
distributions in
log space and the softmax should still
be
a valid you know distribution and then
the lambda
is exponentiated by k and k now properly
runs from the 0 2 all the way
up the stacks
so big l would be the total number of
layers
and little l would be the layer where
you're currently
at and you can clearly see that the
contribution
of these attention matrices it
is so lambda would be something smaller
than one
and therefore the contribution is
in the current layer is the strongest
but also in the next one up
is a bit weaker then one more up is even
a bit weaker and so on
so you'd still have essentially the same
mechanism as hidden is suggesting
controlling for the fact that things are
in different branches of the parse tree
alright back to classic yannick who is
thoroughly confused by these things
yeah i'm not good at i'm not good at
coming up with math on the spot
but i hope you can see what it's doing
so
it is if if you simply take the first k
you would simply stay at that layer and
it would be what hinton said
but what i'm saying is you should also
consider
how much your top
your higher layer one layer up from you
agrees with one layer up from the thing
you want to attend to
so you also compute that inner product
between
between uh the embeddings and you add
that to the soft max distribution so
initially the softmax distribution would
be like you should detend to
this thing and this thing and this thing
a lot
but then the next up hierarchy
would maybe say well we agree because
you know these are in the same thing
but this one maybe not so much and you
would add those together maybe with a
lambda factor in here
and then you go one layer up and it
would say well okay everything over here
basically agrees right and here no
but everything over here basically
doesn't agree so you would add that
maybe with a lambda squared as you go up
the layers
it would be less and less important but
still you'd consider it
all right you know if this is going to
work out
uh inside the channel now back to
what hinton says this this is actually
the system this
is the system as in a nutshell
you're gonna input the image at the
bottom
and hinton says you could use like a
convnet at the very bottom to get it
into the columns but then you're going
to
every time step pass information up the
columns down the columns
and between the same layer of the
different columns
and that's going to in some points
this is going to stabilize i don't know
if it has cycles he probably doesn't
have cycles this is
l probably does not have cycles
so at some point this comes to an end
and if that comes to an
end it should be that the
object level embeddings agree on an
object
the part level embeddings agree on what
parts there are the sub
parts agree and so on and they form
these islands these islands give rise to
a parse tree
and the parse tree can tell you what
object is there what is it made of
and where are these parts in the image
and so on
so exactly
that is it and now we're going to look
at
what hinton calls some design decisions
how many levels are there about five
okay we can skip that
how fine-grained are the locations
hidden says
you could be as fine-grained as pixels
or they could correspond to
larger image patches you and he says you
could
do convolutional neural network to get
it
in there does the bottom up net look at
nearby locations
he says yes the bottom up net
so this this is not the attention
network that's the bottom up network
it could look at nearby locations but
hinton imagines that
if you have bottom up top down and if
you have attention
drawing in information and if you maybe
limit that attention to a neighborhood
then um then the
the attention will do the job because
you can have instead of looking at
neighboring locations in the bottom up
network
you can simply in two time steps
aggregate that information
so you can do bottom up here bottom up
here
and then using the attention the lateral
mechanism you can pass that information
around this way
and also it is not as biasing
the network to the immediate
neighborhood
so the attention mechanism can sort of
look farther
which conflicts with what he's saying on
top that the attention mechanism might
only be looking at the neighbors
i think there are different
possibilities here
and only looking at neighbors is
actually one of the solution
to the problem of having you know kind
of
similar vectors at very distant
locations at down the levels
but i think it's not as as good a
solutions to simply look at
how close things are in pixel space
because even though things are closed in
pixel space
they might be far away in the parse tree
space
how does the attention work we've
already looked at this
so the way that one location
attends to another location is going to
be the soft max of the inner product
between the embeddings here and the
values are also going to be just
the embedding set layer at that
layer the visual input
that he says convolutional net could be
used
color and texture um he says
he make he gives this example like if
you know if an object
is entirely pale or entirely green
or entirely i don't even know how to
pronounce this the color of a part is
straightforward
but what color is the whole object so
this entire notion
of um capsules by the way hinton
imagines this as these embeddings
represent kind of properties of
the object so that the the cat
ear embedding represents not only the
fact that it is a cat ear but also
different
properties about the cat ear and even
its location
in the image is in the embedding and you
know we know that transformers
they must be doing something like this
because we feed in positional embeddings
for example at the very bottom
and it can still you know compute things
in terms of positions so um
that's the there's an intrinsic
connection between kind of
capsules and the kind of
transformer architecture he says
one of the motivations of glom was the
idea that the whole object
has a compound color which might be
called pale green or
mauve and at the object level
every location belonging to the object
has exactly the same compound color
so the object is whatever this all over
when deciding which other locations the
object level attend to preference would
be given to locations with a similar
compound color
so um what he's saying right here is
that
you know you could give preference to to
similar
color locations when you decide
what you want to attend to but the color
isn't as easy as simply saying what
color is there
in the location that you are at
but you could be so if this is green
and this here is blue then
the bottom layer would say yes i'm green
and yes i'm blue but they could also be
saying
well i am part of a green blue object
right and then the the higher layer here
you know attending or caring about
multiple or
bigger region its color would then be
you know green blue and the consensus
could reach on
well we are a green blue object even
though the object
isn't a pure green or pure blue all
throughout
so he um i think yeah
it's it's i think it's a side suggestion
maybe he
has this as a core motivation between
the system
but um it's just interesting to see how
he thinks of things and he extends
the color here to textures and even
shapes the individual texture elements
have their own
shapes and poses in spatial
relationships but an object
with a textured surface has exactly the
same texture everywhere
at the object level column extends these
ideas to
shapes an object may have parts that are
very
different from one another but at the
object level it has exactly the same
compound shape
in all of the location that it occupies
basically saying that
okay every pixel that's part of a cat
head
is a is a cat head has the shape of a
cat head even though the individual
locations might not recognize
that and that information could be
passed around
through this consensus mechanism over
time
so the cluster discovery versus cluster
formation
we've seen that and he makes a lot of um
he makes a lot of analogies to face
recognition but yeah the clusters are
not
the islands of similar embedding vectors
at a level can be viewed as clusters but
these clusters are not discovered in
immutable data
they are formed by the interaction
between the intra-level
process that favors islands of
similarity and dynamically changing
suggestions
coming from the locations embedding at
adjacent levels
so the core here is really this
consensus algorithm
that creates these clusters and
yeah the clustering algorithm doesn't
work by simply looking at embeddings and
deciding which ones go together
but the embeddings themselves update
themselves in order to
form clusters
and yeah this is replicating embedding
vectors this is a
response to a criticism that i i guess
he got where someone said
well why don't why do you represent if
you have these
you know these columns at the bottom it
makes sense you have all the different
vectors but then
as you go up you know you have that kind
of the same vector for all
locations because it's the same object
why does it make sense to replicate that
everywhere
and not just have one because you know
in a database we just have one
and hidden basically says that in order
to reach the consensus first of all it's
important to have different vectors they
might be slightly different so they
might have some nuance
in them because you know they might get
pulled into different directions
from the kind of bottom-up signal than
from the consensus algorithm on the same
layer
so i you know i i believe that it is
that is important
uh here i think it's just this is a
criticism he got
and then he decided to put this in here
learning islands so what we haven't
discussed about this
yet is how this is trained hinton says
this is trained as a denoising auto
encoder
let us assume that glom is trained to
reconstruct at its output
the uncorrupted version of an image from
which
some region has been have been removed
so he goes into uh self-supervised
learning with this system
this objective should ensure that
information about the input is preserved
during the forward pass and if the
regions are sufficiently large
it should also ensure that identifying
familiar objects
will be helpful for filling in the
missing regions
to encourage islands of near identity
we need to add a regularizer and
experience shows that a regular asset
simply encourages similarity between the
embeddings of nearby locations can cause
representations to collapse
all the embedding vectors may become
very small
so that they are all very similar and
the reconstruction will then use very
large weights to deal with the very
small scale
to prevent collapse and then he says
contrastive learning
is the answer to this so how do you
regularize the model
such that this consensus is formed he
says
contrastive learning might be
useful but you can't simply apply it
straight out
so it learns to make representations of
two different crops of the same image
agree
and the representations of two crops
from different images disagree but this
is not a sensible thing to do
if our aim is to recognize objects if
crop 1 contains objects a and b and crop
from the same image contains objects b
and c
it does not make sense to demand that
the representation of the two crops is
the same
at the object level okay so
he says that contrastive learning is
good
but you have to pay very careful
attention at which
layer you employ it
because you know if you go down far
enough then contrastive learning
especially
you know this this type where you crop
the image
into different parts and you say well
since it's the same image the
representations should agree hinton
would say well at the top layer yes but
at the bottom layer certainly not
because they display
different things right so you have to be
careful where you
apply this contrastive learning
and he gives a bunch of suggestions on
how to solve that
he says things like well negative
examples for example might not
might not even be be needed well that's
it
sorry that's a different thing so the
obvious solution is to regularize
uh the bottom up and top down neural
networks by encouraging
each of them to predict the consensus
object option
yeah this is the way to geometric mean
of the predictions coming from the top
down and bottom-up networks
the attention-weighted average of the
embeddings at nearby locations
at the previous time step the previous
state of
and i guess end there should be an end
here and the previous state of the
embedding
training the intra-level prediction to
agree with the consensus will clearly
make the islands found during feed
forward inference be
more coherent so
he says you could regularize the model
to to regress to the consensus option so
it's sort of like a self a self
regression um
and he asks whether or not that will
lead to a collapse
because if you don't have negative
examples and contrastive learning
this could lead to simply a collapse
an important question is whether this
type of training
will necessarily cause collapse if it is
not accompanied by training the
inter level predictions to be different
for negative examples that use the
consensus options for
unrelated spatial contexts so here
is that problem right if you use the
consensus
opinion for unrelated spatial context
that might be a problem he says
using layerer batch norm should reduce
the tendency to collapse but a more
important consideration may be the
achievability of
the goal it goes into why
regularization could help um
and he says if however an embedding at
one location is free to choose which
embeddings at other locations it should
resemble
the goal can be achieved almost
perfectly by learning to form islands of
identical vectors and attending almost
entirely to other locations that are in
the same
island and i don't know i don't know
if this is what i suggested
so i guess this is kind of a convoluted
paragraph and i had to also read it
multiple times and i still
don't exactly know what he's trying to
say right here
but i think what he's saying is that
what we want to do is we want to sort of
regularize
the network to produce this consensus
right
so we have a bottom-up signal a top-down
signal we have a current
value and we have the signal from the
attention
mechanism now what we want to do is we
want to
reach a consensus such that these
islands form
however if you attend to any sort of
things here that have nothing to do with
you
you might not be able to reach this
consensus
right that's i think that's the problem
i i think he's touching on the problem
that i said before
so what he says is you know
what you should do is you should simply
attend to things
that are in the same islands already
so if an embedding at one location is
free to choose which embedding at other
locations it should resemble
the goal can be achieved by learning to
form islands of identical vectors
and attending almost entirely to other
locations that are in the same
island now i think here
what he's doing he makes the case for
the attention mechanism itself
right so he says if if we simply draw in
information from the same layer here you
know
anything any old information might come
in
and we might collapse and or we might
never reach consensus because
any old information might come in
however if we introduce the attention
mechanism
into this whole thing and only draw in
information
from the selected neighbors that already
are in the same group in the same island
as me
then this consensus algorithm works so
if the network
the network is now forced kind of to
learn to build these islands of similar
things
in order to make this consensus work if
we
regularize this consensus so i
believe he makes the case for the
attention
mechanism i don't think he in this case
considers kind of the
up the next up layer islands
what i would say is you need to consider
the island membership
all the way up the columns in order to
decide
which things which locations right
it's free to choose which embeddings at
other locations it should resemble
i think yeah this is the case for the
attention mechanism
okay i hope you're still half with me
um if not i'm i'm a bit confused too
but i think what he's doing is he says
contrastive learning would be good you
can use it but you have to be careful
at which layer you do it another
regularizer to form these islands
would be this regularize the network to
conform to the consensus option opinion
however if you simply aggregate
information from the same
layer then that wouldn't work because
you know the different things in the
same layer might correspond to
completely different parts of the image
drawing in information from there would
not help you
how do you solve this by introducing the
very attention mechanism that he
introduced in order to only draw in
information
from parts of the same layer that
actually
are related to you
okay the next
thing the next consideration he does is
representing coordinate
transformations so how does this
represent coordinate transformations
there was a capsule net paper
where he explicitly represents
coordinate transformations
in kind of four dimension quaternion
space
and he he says that is probably
not needed because you don't want to
here says you could represent this
by a
by four by four matrices however
if you simply allocate 16 numbers in
each embedding vector
in order to represent the part whole
coordinate transformation
like the transformation that relates the
part to the whole that does not make it
easy to represent uncertainty about
aspects of pose and certainty about
others
so the problem here is that we know that
humans when they watch something
right here uh when they watch a scene
like this is a chair
and there is a person a very tiny person
on the chair
we don't see necessarily the coordinate
frame of the world
what we see is we see the coordinate
frame of the chair
like maybe this is the center and we see
the person in relation
to the chair our brain seems to do this
intuitively
and hinton thinks that a system like
this should also do it intuitively
so somehow the coordinate
transformations
involved going from the eye to the
reference through the frame of the chair
and then
from the chair to the person they should
be somehow
in encoded in this network however
he also says that it's probably not
necessary
to encode them explicitly as you know
explicit coordinate transformations
because not only
does that make it harder probably to
learn but also
you can't represent uncertainty in fact
you can represent uncertainty that's the
next thing right here
much better by having a higher
dimensional thing that you're trying to
guess right if you are trying to
guess a distribution with three
components
and you simply have a three-dimensional
vector you have no way of representing
uncertainty
however if you have a nine-dimensional
vector you can have
three opinions about the distribution so
this is an opinion
this is an opinion and then this is an
opinion
and then you can sort of aggregate and
you can say well i'm pretty sure
about these two things because all my
opinions are pretty close
but this one here i'm not so sure
because
uh my individual things say different
things
things say things all right i've this
video is too long
um so that's his argument right here we
don't need explicit
representing of uncertainty because
by simply over parameterizing we can
already
represent uncertainty well
and we also don't need disentangled
position information and
and so on um
sorry we don't need different position
informations
because again the network can take care
of that
and he gives a good example like why
would you have disentangled coordinate
frame if you have an
image and in the image
the picture in it is this
how do you know if that is a rhomboid
shape or if it is a
um if it is a rectangular piece of paper
viewed from the side
i should probably draw it way closer
something like
something like this ah i suck at this
you you get probably get what i mean
like if it is a different
object it has a like the object
and the coordinate transformation are
dependent upon each other
and so it makes sense for the neural
network to actually entangle the two
because the two things depend on each
other
in essence he's just saying don't worry
about explicitly representing
all of the different things we got it
like the neural network can do
all of these things like uncertainty or
position
and post transformations so here he
compares it
to different other architectures
comparison to cnn comparison to
uh transformers comparison to capsule
models
and at the end it goes into video at the
very beginning he says
the paper is about actually a video
system
and you can kind of see that because we
go
through this algorithm in multiple time
steps
right you have it's it's like you
analyze an image with these columns
which gives you sort of a 3d
3d tensor with the image at the bottom
and you go in the next time step you
have a new
3d tensor right you pass this whole
information around
with the image at the bottom and says
why does that need to be the same image
that could also be different images
so you could use the system to analyze
video
so what he does is he says at the same
time
you do this time step to find agreement
you could actually
swap out the video frame the x you can
swap out the video frame
pro and produce a slightly different
video frame and you could actually have
a kind of an
ensemble regularizing effect so as the
whole
columns here the whole system comes to a
consensus over time
you feed in different information at the
bottom
and what he says is that you know if
this is a slow enough video
then um the top players here
would probably could still reach an
agreement while the bottom layers
would change rapidly but that could be
sort of
an ensemble or a regularizer a
regularizing
effect that it even has so he
intrinsically
connects these two time dimensions
because they would be separate right you
could input a video
and then in you know in each frame you
could do this
um consensus finding algorithm but he
says
no it's actually cool to consider them
together to do the consensus finding
while you sort of watch the video it's
just not clear that
you always need the same amount of
consensus finding steps
as you need as you have video frames so
maybe
you wanna maybe you wanna take like five
consensus steps per video frame or the
other way around
not sure in any case i think that's a
pretty cool idea
and he says things like
if the changes are rapid there is no
time available
to iteratively settle on a good set of
embedding vectors for interpreting a
specific
frame this means that the glom
architecture cannot correctly interpret
complicated shapes
if the images are changing rapidly try
taking an irregularly shaped potato
and throwing it up in the air such a way
that it rotates at one or two cycles per
second
even if you smoothly track the potato
you cannot see what shape it is
now i i don't have a potato but i can
give you an avocado so if you give me a
second
how's that could you track the shape i
don't know
probably hinton's correct
all right then he talks about is this
biologically
plausible and i i don't want to go too
much into this he discusses
some restrictions like you know we still
use backprop
and his back plausible and so on um i
love this sentence in the long run
however we are all dead
and then the footnote saying there are
alternative facts
uh but yeah he discusses whether it's
biologically plausible
how could you modify it to make it more
plausible for example
when you want to do contrastive learning
there is evidence that dreams during so
during sleep you do contrastive learning
like you produce the negative examples
during
sleep and then during the day you
collect the positive examples and so on
so
i think this is a more speculative part
of the paper but it's
pretty cool to um
it's pretty cool to read it and lastly
he goes into discussion
he also says like this paper is too long
already
i'm gonna just briefly talk about this
and
he trashes the neurosymbolic people a
bit like he trashes the people
that say no no
you know neural networks can never do
whatever and he says pretty clearly look
um neural networks can represent trees
i've given you a system
also bert can output parse trees so
shut up i guess and he comes up with
this uh
glombert name
which you know is is already coined if
you wanted to do glombert
that's already taken sorry um
i also by the way also coined then i
coined the name
may
[Music]
right now okay if you wanna if you wanna
use it
it better be a pretty cool machine
learning system
and be based on glom right that was the
paper
um i think it's a cool system it has a
bunch of parts that are maybe not
super friendly to hardware at the time
like this iterative procedure
but honestly it is not much more than a
neural network
sorry a recurrent neural network with
very complicated
recurrence functions the video extension
might be a bit tricky and but the rest
and the regularization might be a bit
tricky the exact objective so the
denoising autoencoder objective
isn't super detailed in the paper he
simply says reconstruct the corrupted
version of the input
um how exactly the input happens maybe
there's a cnn maybe the cnn feeds
information into actually multiple
layers none of that is
exactly specified so there's lots to
figure out
i do think the ideas are very cool
and i love idea papers
and therefore i recommend that if you're
interested more
give this thing a read give this video a
like
share it out and i'll see you next time
bye